Did you get 3 x minus 4 y equals negative 8? If so, that is awesome. Now what
makes this problem easier than the last one? Well first, the slope is given, so
we don't have to calculate the slope. The other is if we look at the point 0, 2.
The point 0, 2 is actually the y intercept because x is 0 and y is 2. Now if we
know the slope and we know the y intercept, we can very easily use a slope
intercept form and write y equals mx plus b which equals 3 4th times x plus 2
which is the y intercept. Since we want to write the equation in standard form,
I'm going to go ahead and multiply the equation through by 4. Giving me 4y
equals 3x plus 8. And if I want to write this in standard form. I need to move
the 3x over to the other side. Which would give me negative 3x plus 4 y equals
8. Now you might be asking, why is this answer different from this answer? Well,
they're actually the same. If I were to take this equation and multiply the
whole equation through by negative 1, I'm going to get negative 1 times negative
3x gives me 3x negative 1 times positive 4y gives me negative 4y and negative 1
times positive 8 gives me negative 8. So as you can see this equation negative
3x plus 4y equals 8 is the same as the equation 3x minus 4y equals negative 8
Our convention typically use a math is that we do not have a negative
coefficient to our x variable.